lo que quiero que hagamos en este vídeo
es obtener un poco de práctica y de
intuición acerca de las multiplicaciones
de números que tienen varios dígitos
digamos por ejemplo que queremos saber
cuánto es 7.000 por 6 gray y tal vez a
algunos de ustedes les parezca súper
claro que aquí lo que tenemos es siete
miles y que entonces si multiplicamos
siete de alguna cosa por seis lo que
tenemos realmente es siete por seis de
esa cosa que en este caso son miles ok o
sea que tenemos 42 miles o sea 42 mil y
entonces tal vez pueda llegar súper
rápido a la respuesta y decir ok
tenemos aquí 42 que 7 por 6 42 mil estás
súper bien si puedes llegar así de
rápido a la respuesta y bueno hay muchas
formas de pensar en esto incluso tal vez
puedes haber dicho simplemente
aunque ya tenemos aquí 7000 queremos
multiplicar por 6 6 por 0 es 0 6 por 0
es 0 6 por cerveceros y 6 por 7 es 42 y
listo también estás súper bien y también
puedes decir ok tenemos 6 por 7 42 y
después 3 ceros entonces tenemos que
poner 3 ceros por aquí sin embargo yo
quiero que sepas exactamente qué es lo
que está pasando de fondo aquí y además
eso nos va a ayudar a repasar algunas
propiedades de la multiplicación hawker
y 7000 son siete miles o sea 7 por mil
que también lo podemos escribir como mil
por 7
y lo estamos multiplicando por 6 b por 6
entonces sí estamos multiplicando
primero 1000 por 7 para obtener 7000
podemos poner por aquí unos paréntesis
lo que hay aquí tenemos 7 miel y lo
estamos multiplicando por seis sin
embargo la propiedad asociativa de la
multiplicación lo que nos dice que bueno
ese es simplemente un nombre un poco
elegante pero lo que nos dice es que no
importa el orden en el que
multipliquemos a estos números aunque
ahí podríamos primero multiplicar al 7
por 6 y después multiplicar por mil y
eso es lo que vamos a hacer ahorita ok
entonces tenemos por aquí
por y como vamos a multiplicar 7 por 6
primero entonces pues podríamos ponerlos
entre paréntesis
ok 7
6 y observa podemos multiplicar primero
7 por mil y obtener 7000 o podemos
multiplicar primero 7 por 6 y nos queda
42 que después tenemos que multiplicar
por mil ok entonces podemos ver esto
como mil veces 42 o de una forma más
intuitiva como 42 veces 1000 que es 42
mil así es que otra vez obtenemos 42 mil
y claro yo sé que tú pudiste haber hecho
esto directamente en tu cabeza sin pasar
por todo esto pero es importante saber
qué es lo que está pasando en el fondo y
la otra razón por la que estamos
haciendo esto es porque los ejercicios
de khan academy te piden que hagas esto
para asegurarse que estás entendiendo
cómo puedes partir estás
multiplicaciones en pedazos más fáciles
de multiplicar
y como utiliza la propiedad asociativa
de la multiplicación pero bueno hagamos
otro ejemplo crear y necesitamos más
espacio digamos que ahora tú quieres
saber cuánto es 56 por 8 y bueno hay
muchísimas formas de resolver esta
multiplicación una de ellas es decir ok
tenemos aquí 56 que son cinco decenas o
sea 50 más 6 unidades o sea más 6 todo
este número 56 lo queremos multiplicar
por ocho y entonces podemos distribuir
la multiplicación tomamos 50 por 8 5
decenas por 8
más seis por ocho más
seis unidades por ocho y ahora aquí
tenemos cinco decenas por ocho y bueno
cinco por ocho es cuarenta pero no
estamos simplemente multiplicando cinco
por ocho estamos multiplicando cinco
decenas entonces lo que tenemos son
cuarenta decenas que también se conoce
como 440 decenas una forma muy fácil de
pensar en esto es decir ok 50 es 5 por
10 y 5 por 8 es 40 pero nos falta
multiplicar por 10 entonces
multiplicamos por 10 y listo y bueno 6
por 8 por supuesto que es igual a 48 así
es que esto es igual a 400 400 48 48 y
bueno de hecho así exactamente así es
como lo hago yo en mi cabeza no escribo
todo esto
pero si digo bueno tengo que multiplicar
56 por 8 y cómo puedo partir el 56 pues
lo puedo partir como 56 y listo con un
poco más de práctica vas a poder hacer
esto en tu cabeza súper bien y si te
sirve de algo podemos visualizar esta
multiplicación observando el área de un
rectángulo
así es que observa este rectángulo y
digamos que esta longitud de aquí la
altura del rectángulo es 88 y digamos
también que la longitud de este lado del
rectángulo esta longitud de aquí es 56
gray 56 entonces el área de todo el
rectángulo va a ser 8 x 56 que es justo
la cantidad que nosotros queremos saber
ok 8 por 56 y entonces lo que podemos
hacer es dividir a 56
dos pedazos más fáciles de multiplicar
vamos a dividirlo en este pedazo de aquí
este pedazo de aquí que mide 50 y en
este otro pedazo de aquí este pedazo de
aquí que mide 6 y la razón por la que
estamos dividiendo a esta longitud en
estos dos pedazos es porque es más fácil
calcular en la cabeza cuánto es 8 por 58
por 6 y después sumar esos dos
resultados que hacerlo todo directamente
y entonces lo que estamos haciendo es
calcular estas dos áreas por separado y
después sumarlas para obtener el área
total del rectángulo angle que es la
multiplicación de 8 por 56
así es que cuál es el área de este
rectángulo amarillo
cuál es la multiplicación de 8 por 50
pues 8 por 50 es 400
y luego cuánto es 8 por 6 pues 8 por 6
es 48 y entonces 8 por 56 que es el área
de todo el rectángulo completo es la
suma del área de estos dos rectángulos
osea 448 400 más 48 y esta es la forma
de visualizar con un problema de área
cómo podemos hacer de una forma más
fácil esta multiplicación